Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Using light simulation programs, we are able
to populate a virtual scene with objects,
assign material models to them, and create
a beautiful, photorealistic image of this
digital scene.
The theory of light transport follows the
physics of light, therefore these images should
be indistinguishable from reality, and fortunately,
they often are.
However, there are some cases when we can
tell them apart from real images.
And the reason for this is not the inaccuracies
of the light transport algorithm, but the
oversimplifications used in the geometry and
material models.
The main issue is that in our mathematical
models, these materials are often defined
to be too perfect.
But in reality, metals are rarely perfectly
polished, and the classical material models
in light transport can rarely capture these
microstructures that make surfaces imperfect.
This algorithm is about rendering new material
models that can represent the imperfect materials
like scratched coating and metallic flakes
on carpaint, a leather sofa, wooden floor,
or a teapot.
Just look at these phenomenal images.
Previous techniques exist to solve this problem,
but they take extremely long and are typically
limited to flat surfaces.
One of the main difficulties of the problem
is that these tiny flakes and scratches are
typically orders of magnitude smaller than
a pixel, and therefore they require a lot
of care and additional computations to render.
This work provides an exact, closed-form solution
to this that is highly efficient to render.
It is over a hundred times faster than previous
techniques, has less limitations as it works
on curved surfaces, and, it only takes 40%
longer to render it compared to the standard
perfect material models.
Only 40% more time for this?
Sign me up!
It is truly incredible that we can create
images of this sophistication using science.
It is also highly practical as it can be plugged
in as a standard material model without any
crazy modifications to the simulation program.
Looking forward to seeing some amazing animations
using more and more realistic material models
in the near future.
If you would like to learn more about light
simulations, I have been holding a full master-level
course on it at the Technical University of
Vienna for a few years now.
After a while, I got a strong feeling that
the teachings shouldn't only be available
for the lucky 30 people in the classroom who
can afford a college education.
The teachings should be available for everyone.
And now, the entirety of this course is available
free of charge for everyone where we learn
the theory of light from scratch and implement
a really cool light simulation program together.
If you want to solve a few infinite dimensional
integrals with me, give it a go!
As always, details are available in the video
description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!